all right and we are live welcome to the
iron Lords podcast episode number 59
it's another glorious Sunday and we are
back at the roundtable on the Lord's Day
we've got to launch an impact of God of
War media bias changes at Microsoft
Studios and Call of Duty single-player
to discuss so we're gonna get right into
it so let's introduce the four horsemen
of gaming those usual suspects at the
round table
my co-host with the Comox my brother
from another mother the difficult game
Conqueror and the how of the young wolf
mom made Lord addict are you doing sir
what's up you guys yeah enthusiastic how
I like it
of course we have our most technical
gaming Lord the solo gamer who lives for
the single player selfish experience and
also the sastra Davis mr. off loan
profile Illuminati himself mommy no its
sovereign are you doing sir my good man
with club guy you know on that crack you
guys pulled me away from my crack the
lord of combat sports was a man of his
convictions demands nothing less than
the premium experience it is to get
money game
go get down you can do it be lovely Lord
King how you doing sir we're doing
fantastic everybody god of the fight
last night was in the King's favor
alright and also we had some charlatans
and some snake oil salesmen out here
giving you the unreal
while Showtime is out here dishing that
real just like God when God was that
real Showtime
got that real let's go - lets go through
that fake first let's hit that fake
first that fool's gold
that idiot sauce let's get to that first
right check it out last night Eddie
snakes salesman Holmes had his little
card out there in the UK shout-out to UK
gamers shoutout to the UK fight lovers
Eddie Hearn is asleep alright well he
hey young man Aamir Khan coming back a
man King Kong last time we saw Aamir
Khan he was flat on his back on Illidan
strips is my body all right we all know
Aamir Khan does not have a chin so
remember what I told you guys about
tomato cans yes young man and young man
and cherry picked the best tomato kid he
could find and when he put him in ring
with a man King Kong what happens when
you put talent against hard work the
hard work is garbage the hard work that
was garbage got stretched out in 51
seconds whoa you heard me right folks
whoa 51 no it would know it was not part
of the show time do not mix that with
show time okay
don't now don't you feel down yeah okay
that's fool's gold everybody's gonna
think of milk on his back and they gonna
put him in there with somebody who got a
punch and a mere car is gonna die okay
he's gonna die all right yeah we had
call Frampton against the needs of doing
there let me tell you something people
um you're gonna have this is gonna be
the theme of the evening
it's our hard work versus talent all
right Nia has supreme talent his talent
ridiculous in his heyday you have called
Frampton who was the hard work he was I
out work you so exactly what happened
was he got out worked and now it showed
up some but it wasn't enough because it
wasn't backed by hard work don't hear
you still got some left in the tank you
have to be matched properly and you have
to train differently you have to you
have to reinvent yourself like Holyfield
did true you my friend did not be in the
ring with anybody that's gonna outpace
you it was a great fight all Showtime
cards are great fight that was a
Showtime what else we got
javante take Davis Oh Davis forgetting
focus young man 21 years old you got
everything going for you right now your
accuracy you know your boxing technique
that half uppercut that he was throwing
he kept him in his body with a half
uppercut that made his legs said not
tonight all right so that's when you mix
talent with work ethic
he's a result he knocked him out in the
third round
Dave Dave day all right check this out
now you my man Jamal Charlo this is when
I spend my TV oh yes I told her I tell
everybody about this beast this savage
this monster of a man he's a twin his
father produced two of the most savage
boxes you do not want your life in the
ring with okay this this is this is
Talent
he was facing again hard work hard work
tried hard work brought his lunch spell
and he thought tonight would be his name
Jamal charlo hit him
that one to that one hitter quitter
folded his knee back into his body
slant he he was everybody thought he was
dead folks I'm so sorry but it was a
young literally I came in short hours
and I saw a man that look like he got
shot down by a sniper so I asked who is
why the best knockout you're gonna see
so far this first half of the year and
then we're gonna get to Adrien Broner
the highlight of the card versus Jesse
Vargas - Vargas is hard work folks Jesse
Vargas is a mexican-american guy who
works very hard at his craft Adrien
Broner is a very highly talented black
American
these two Americans were in the ring or
brash trash-talking and they weren't
producing what you expected the reason
why they weren't producing what you
expected is because one was it just
enough dude alright now we call them
just enough ninjas if you understand
what I'm saying he's happy with just
enough you cuz he has talent and he
doesn't work hard enough because he
doesn't want to risk without risk
there's no reward Adrian what else blood
sweat and tears they're willing to put
your body into the fire and die for what
you're talking about cuz you got a big
mouth
Adrian your mouth is so big but your
skill set doesn't back it up enough
Floyd so stop and shoulder rolling mind
talking put those hands together and let
them hands go you thought about changing
trainings that something different was
gonna happen but you had the same exact
words oh and you're the same exact thing
coming from the corner so it's not those
people that's behind you it is you my
friend good point I'm glad you said that
king of the country because he I love
what the corner was saying to him every
round they were being real with him he's
in his own head about how great he think
he is as opposed to what he actually
produces but continue I'm sorry no no no
he we was talking about it yesterday
you will part
conversation going back and forth and
you saw it tried to do was fool you when
he heard that Bell we could we call him
ten-second suckers fight you got ten
seconds suckers and they hear that Bell
and they know in 10 seconds say but
we'll be saved because they be able to
go sit down in the corner you know that
he throw the hardest bell ring that's
the most action you know one white when
when the Bell spots again they come out
the first middle around and they don't
give you exactly what they just left you
with it's what I fool you into thinking
that it's going to be something else I
scored it it draws well I had Jesse
Vargas with his great talent I mean with
his great hard work went in the first
six rounds yes then talent showed up at
age and Bruno a Jim browner would have
worked hard given to the fight exactly
yeah it would have code he it's exactly
what he said that's my problem when I'm
like he's so talented but it's just like
like you said can he just doesn't work
hard and if he came on late and it's
like he's gonna put this same energy in
the first six it would have been a
no-doubter like I know why he doesn't do
it because the first six rounds that
person is very dangerous and enviable
he's afraid yeah he has a heart of a
mustard seed he's not a true Adrian you
are undercard fighter and I'm tired of
you I'm tired of looking for you to show
up I'm tired of you Bozeman at the end
of the fight you are highly
disrespectful you were rude
it wasn't our sportsman to my friend or
what though the worst of all of us
ninjas
you're the worst that we have to offer
you are not a pay-per-view fighter
you'll never be Floyd Floyd no matter
what he said he always conducted himself
there's a sportsman in a businessman was
never disrespectful unless when he went
I won do and he apologized about it
because he was highly upset because he
gave his all in the ring you do not give
you all sir you are not Floyd you need
to go away you're under car anything
that you're part of I don't want to be a
part of and UFC
let's get that card into yeah I actually
started with solved what solved what hat
what have you seen for you
oh you did honestly I focused on I saw a
lot of under cars but as I said to you
guys before we started we got a warhead
C and boxing off this lab I'm watching
it but it's all music when I'm paying
attention to the stuff on the side I'm
like alright I'm checking out these
fights so I paid attention really -
Edgar versus Cub Swanson and barbosa
versus Lee though the two main fights on
the cards that's what I would sense so
what was your assessment of both Oh
Edgar again Edgar after losing Brian
Ortega a guy who's like just his
physical attributes this kind of
overtook Edgar the guys young the guy's
talented the guy's strong he's just
physically too much for my head Frankie
what Cub Swanson is a guy that that
Frankie tapped out before so and cub is
a great fighter they publicly find it
great fighters after long but it goes to
show you the Frankie despite being in
the game for a long time you can still
perform at that high level his movement
his boxing his takedowns his defense
all-around skill in the Octagon shows
and it showed against Cubs wants a cub
is is the type of guy who's gonna stand
he's gonna eat throw punches with you
he's not really big about being on the
floor although he is a pretty good
tutors who practitioner um and a
wrestler but I mean again Frankie
Frankie just did what he needed to do to
be Cub Swanson um no no the thing is
he's a smart fighter he's at the point
in his life he can't go toe-to-toe with
these guys exactly and generally
everybody's bigger than him even guys to
be honest because to me I always feel
he's always on the sides and everybody
and he's his skill level is so much and
he's so busy so accurate like it's such
a testament he just did a quick
turnaround against Ortega so everybody
was questioning like yo what are you
doing you just got stretched and then
you came back up here with her and to be
he woke up and copped it what pissed me
off about the five years I Cobb didn't
want it like yeah your covers usually a
lot more aggressive like I'm like you
packing like you fighting this super
imposing fighter and I don't think don't
disrespect the Frankie like I was very
disappointed with Cub I'm being real
with you because I like
and I know is capable of so to see him
so tentative
and and and the first fight was
competitive until when when Frankie took
him down like Frankie has the ability to
ground and pound you to death if he
takes you down great wrestler he just he
got his back and choked them out but I
mean cub was a very competitive fight I
just found out about it myself I gotta
look into him but you shot them I know
the he dabbed after his with that was
kind of this big oh this won't get
breezed through real quick and we get
into it all shout - uh you know
obviously was in Jersey last night you
know not too far from where I'm at so a
shout to Jersey Jim Miller but uh Boyd a
hooker all my the best me I've ever seen
it was so perfectly time slump this boy
put him to sleep oh my lord I felt bad
for Jim Jim Elam and I was just a
perfect knee hook i watch our families
on the rise same thing but you saw with
Eddie versus club you know say Frankie's
back he's back in the mix we'll see what
happens with him but I gotta talk about
that made of nature both both both
coming off losses Kevin leader Ferguson
you know I'm saying he had a staph
infection with that one this way that's
a loss yeah he lost a Ferguson he was
dominating Ferguson and then but he came
in with a staph infection and he after
the second round he faded he gassed out
and what I was worried about Kevin Lee
the crowd with him is that he always has
weight issues and like that he missed
weight again they had to fight at a
catchweight
so he had to give some in his purse so
his dedication is still a little off
like this he's young he's got so much
talent
he's so good like he pretty much could
do it all but it's like he's got to get
together but Bowl just came off for them
the mauling from cabina bolter could
strike like his feet is crazy so long
story short first two miles chemistry
dominating like it was the best
performance from coming up every house
an old cabbage ready he's ready then the
turnaround came and I saw something
after what I would never see uh around
house being not aroused the standing
kick to the top of Kevin Lee's head and
Kevin Lee cell phone went off and he
didn't know at the grabber call yo-yo
King I've never seen a Boogaloo you know
I'm not sure he's not he's not telling
you how it was going
all right Jude was who's Lee Lee is the
rough dude detective wiggle for the body
right yeah okay now leave without a
given meeting that he has to offer
everything that the advertising he
talked about he was giving him every
elbow he was beating him with this body
it was crazy so crazy
even if y'all watch all the gamers at a
chat
even if y'all do not watch UFC please
you - Kevin Lee vs. Edson Barboza
specifically the third round that's all
like this one that is if you want to see
body betrayal
it is purest form he got it together and
I said I have to open you up right now
yes exactly what he said imma open you
up and he started giving them these
elbows to this side of the head and he
opened him up it looked like you know
when the baby is coming it was the fight
guards please yes beautiful night combat
sports no Atticus's we gotta wake him
back up and get back to do you love that
shirt that was beautiful right I hope
everybody's got these shirts get them we
still got a couple more left to eat
these three shirts are coming but Merc I
know you'll put that shirt up and of
course we have shinobi gaming ninja
himself Laura Cognito spread nebulous in
the realm of the IOP not telling you
what you want to hear but what you need
to hit so obviously you know are you
going to what the Lord's are playing
right now but obviously for the most
part most of the hoods have been uh
playing one specific game but also I
want to do a little something a little
different um I know on Twitter there's
this hashtag going around think I'm not
attic sort for it so called the game
struck four did you see it at it when
people with hash tagging that yeah how
don't keep up with that [ __ ] Debbie and
I figured that most of us always I'm
gonna be forced to keep up with their
now then yes you go you go keep up with
it now cuz I'll set it off to make it
easy for you guys so basically I want to
do is these are the four most
influential
titles to you as a gamer and why so this
was hard this is all for me so pretty
much what I did
looked at my whole game in Korean I say
okay what's the four
most important titles as to why I'm a
game right so first to no surprise to
y'all because it's in my house played it
the arcade version oh you know you know
shinobi's very important obviously the
whole Cognito moniker I'm saying the
whole ninja thing that's my that's my
wave and actually make me fall in love
with Sega and from that point no and I
would go to our cakes look for I
remember seeing that little blue logo no
that games made by saying you know
everything else hang on all our stuff
that's what started the love which
translated to the master system blah
blah blah the second for me is halo 1
and obviously the Lords we've talked
about this many times you know that's
the only game that I think brought an
entire community together like our whole
blocks like we had different
neighborhoods come together right kick
yours just for that halo and this is
halo halo 1 specifically because this is
before the days of xbox lives you know
ain't no one changed
yeah like we've never seen anything
putting the team everyone chipping in
monies for TVs you don't put in a LAN
cable down you know the next man in I
mean we had competitions you know I'm
saying shout out to everybody
childhood Melrose project that we had to
become financially invested in
technology to boost our gaming separate
everybody had to buy a controller but we
had to have four Xbox presents shout out
the little Cognito for having the
technology savvy that he know which
Ethernet cores that we needed to reduce
the back to the women s 19-inch on sale
last minute like a display model they
had nothing else and we display model
for like a hundred bucks
so halos definitely obvious reasons you
know I'm saying the multi player change
games from
the fun times member mr. Howle hang him
high and all those fun maps and blood
goats and just hours upon hours of games
so halo is always gonna place mark the
neck Dora well for me it was hard
because I mean ii had to be a neighbor
which one it had to be Tekken 3 because
I felt that was the pinnacle of the
series not that the series fell off but
it's just like that's when it really
became mainstream I ran character came
out fell in love with that that's when I
used to be in my prime I was on my Bruce
Legion who used to come challenge me
tapped a foot let's get it you know I'm
saying that's the Daisy hey my problems
you know all my problem was I was
serious
and like that's the day solve knows King
knows where we have to do the I am it
challenges your the 10 straight and you
have you fought that man into one of you
had a 10 fight win difference how hard
that is the mental toughness
like that's how Lord forged you know
saying the only man never take my title
one year it was one Matt and I'm not
gonna front the rest of the lords went
downstairs while me and Lord Lola's
decided to go upstairs and get our 10 in
I played a mind game with him because
little eyes technically was better than
me
alright but my mind go in there and I
would talk trash to him to nab him to
give him a funeral attacking but what I
did was I reversed it I was like good
one match right there and then we kept
going I was like good and I was talking
nice to him so I just armed him to the
point mr. gressman wasn't dead but my
aggression was still high because I was
still remembering the crap that he was
talking and I beat the brakes off for
her yes I beat the brakes the ticket
that last match went down I got up and I
yelled
the heartbroken cuz he thought we was
bonding and it was heartbroken he looked
up at me like he know and I ran
downstairs and I proceeded to tell
everybody how at this mansion is that
between Lola's and King there were
always extra side bets yes depending on
one and home for them also to give
context both of them had the greatest
ish talking I've never seen like they
would get so if and laugh so hard offer
everything they would do next a king
Lolo loss was that dude as far as just
talking and being funny you know say so
that's a dude you don't wanna lose to
you know I'm saying those two you can't
lose to these two no it would never hit
end of his greatest I admit you know Ted
streak victories the low last joy you
know say that was that was classic shout
the carboxyl shout out the ohm you know
demon Karras when all that and the last
one for me and I really had to think
about people number like oh I'm not
surprised this one but it's gotta be
done it's got to be because at the end
of the day I've met so many people
through that game and then rating you
know I'm saying Lord King and I was
sinister Lord at it you know saying like
destiny brought us all together
destinies the reason why we you know I'm
saying so at the end of the day I can't
discount shout the bounces I mean I'm
gonna go in a god oh honey and all these
people fall out plays holtzman you don't
I'm saying the list goes on and on and
on and and as Florida's destiny one was
and how it got better than like
obviously the pinnacle moment was like
taking king when you say addict like I
was like the pinnacle you know saying
that was the height of Dustin and it's
just like hit me up and just saying
y'all cog man let's do this heart rate
of how no man
I'm not doing it if you ain't do it in
the king frodo like nor Frodo knows like
I refuse to do the hard taking king ray
it was such a chore you know it's funny
I hated it back then and now I miss it
it is just like I remember we completed
it and it was a dick in the party on us
in the party and we it was like I told I
said you know we brothers for life now
way to Vietnam or like because I was
that raid and just even you know -
destiny - a lot attic filling the dogs
and stuff like it's so many memories and
regardless - like I said what's going on
destiny right now and hopefully it turns
around I can't take away from that
important that impact it had on me as a
gamer so that's my for attic i'ma give
it to you because I want my curious to
your perspective young ball young wolf
what's the four most important games to
you as a game games like franchises or
games like Jessie don't you have to not
game yet you do even if who cares even
if there's some in the corners rated but
for you it impacted you probably Final
Fantasy 7 Legend of Zelda and I'd have
to say the original fable so what you
says Eldo Oh
Final Fantasy seven oh seven and ten
mm-hmm those are the most I recognize my
favorite but at the time those were the
most impactful though for you know and
was the fourth one cuz you were so fast
faithful favor your favorite God I
should ask you to shout out to a planet
like the logo alright loss of Europe for
most impacted game struck for for tough
man tough this is tough I would have to
start with Double Dragon right double
I'm always talking about like me playing
in arcades with
the memories so jealous when a system
solve I remember I got my masters too
early and you got it late and they
started doing some packing deal with
double dragon tight dragon before was in
the stores man like I that's what made
me a good kid that's I had it I had a
choice when I saw that I wasn't now I'm
going with the bigot and that was that I
mean yeah all the times playing an
arcade with Cognito and the rest of my
schoolmates and then just having it in
the house being able to play with my
brother like hmm dealt with dragons got
to be one of them um then Mario 64 mm I
loved I love Mario um on the SNES when I
was you know I was never great a
platformer so that was a hibachi slain
so I can I loved it but it frustrated me
to certain point when he brought it into
3d it was more for me like I got it at
that point
oh okay I get this that for whatever
reason I gravitated more to Italy it was
just a you know revelation of a game
then the ocarina of time whenever time
like has to be my third one because
gonna even yeah it took the Zelda
formula and it you know put it into 3d
in a way that immersed you like never
before like the way the way iced water
filled my god of war right now isn't
like what ocarina did for me back
doesn't wow man it really like oh no God
of War is derivative right winning it
polishes up a lot of those core concepts
all right and then the last one has to
be halo 1 mm and I'm leaving out Tekken
you know because I don't play fighting
games as much anymore but that was
definitely a formative game especially
three just like you um but it would have
to be halo 101 to this day you play halo
1 and heroic to this day it's probably
some of the best enemy AI you're gonna
find in a game in terms of reacting to
specific situations money duck behind
cover how they would flank you later
games in the series don't do it as well
like you something about that game that
really you know and then you know you're
playing the game you're loving it and
then when you go down into the library
and you face the flood for the first
time what is this what is Wednesday's
meditate at that
right it will below legendary it was a
definition of a collab like it's old
Xbox which that game mm-hmm that Lord
King I'm very curious I am so curious
with your choices
what is your four games Amazon I'm
curious because after you say your four
I want to see I want to test you
something could do all right well my
first one is gonna have to be Street
Fighter to all the street fighters and
strip it was the only game that I've
purchased on every platform that I was
able to purchase it on hmm well my
simple love of that game and what it
meant like I seen a guy actually get
stabbed in front of me because he was
cheesing it was real did you told him we
were I was working as a director at a
community center over there are 160 it
was so real did you put his quarter up
and they was fighting and you know he
lost he lifted the guy so you'll stop
chasing me bro right so he had can I'll
never forget it to this day he had Ken
he looked over to Doudna said don't
cheese me again stop cheese me bro hmm
and to do cheese them again he proceeded
to pull out a pocket knife and poke the
brakes off another reason all because we
you guys you brought this dead port for
super 80s for the first time and I
brought my idiot friend over the face I
was trying to say that it was arcade
perfect nobody was trying to hear that
at that time so yes you find it for you
very important yeah I just paid $150 for
my cartridge my Super NES cartridge on
Elizabeth Street canal and LOCOG Nieto
brought his ponytail where
I think that's where my hater ponytails
have Morelli's stand on the side with
his arms folded and go yeah but it's not
arcade perfect cuz partly I will get
this dude jump so fast so now wish me
fight on but give me give me three more
c'mon this the second one has to be halo
one whoa
that's when I lost relationships over
halo one because y'all know y'all know
my ex-girlfriends would say there's no
way in hell that you're playing video
games before and I'm like yeah I don't
know they thought girls was over there
surfing us in your house with drinks or
something I don't know what they thought
but the camaraderie with that game I met
so much great friends enough friends
anymore a family doesn't he just says
you will not be in a car with us I'm
gonna give you a street some street
fighting boxart
when you move it apart don't do that do
not do that ponytail my next game and
it's gonna probably be like yeah I'm
gonna shut up Brussels in a while um I
finished well I played almost every
Zelda that there was but breath little
wild it became part of my my my DNA my
blood of something it got to the point
where I was checking in over 21 amiibos
every 12 hours but my kids thought I was
crazy I had a table right next to me
with every amiibo and I would scan them
in like clockwork every 12 hours no you
didn't do it every 12 hours everything
every 12 hours
I was checking it would be like Matt
just not ready yet he got to the point
know what you mean this one wasn't done
and got to the point where I will come
in and I will have to do it and but the
game was so much fun
the Beast enos in which he was able to
attack the world um I think breath of
the wild really marriage what a 3d
adventure game is supposed to be mm-hmm
the fun the playability the story and
the stories drug you in it was it is
probably the the only game that I will
give a perfect 10 if I would have to
give a ten to a game no give that game a
perfect ten and yes it was Game of the
Year whenever it was released that was
the only game that she should have
played that year my last game will have
to be fighting I was just about to say
because I was like looking if you don't
have a boxing game in your top four I
would have an issue the reason why is
and I'm gonna tell you I played every
boxing game that there was right all the
way up to legends all the way through
from what it was that wrinkles will blow
up yeah but it came together on that
first fight night and we saw Roy Jones I
remember I looked at Cagney
yeah that was the man he was such a fan
of that dude our fan boy out for that
dude because he put my heroes in the
flesh and represented them properly so
that yeah that's my last game I know
probably for some of y'all guys are like
oh shut up King nah yeah for me um it
gave you the feeling when you hit a dude
in the hearing with the brewery oh that
was the punching system when you have to
actually use the analog in motion right
they need a fighter series went away is
it coming they need to come back on
Floyd or something I don't think I was a
solid game impressed looking I didn't
take your time so today I'm very
impressed
that's that way so we gonna move on last
week's poll with results are in and the
people have spoken to the question if
your favorite console company routinely
disappoints you by the decisions or lack
of moves it makes is it okay that
consistently demand more from said
company or console the winner at 61% oh
four way poll cruising to victory was
the yes keep demanding better group
coming in a second place at 18% was the
know if you are that upset get rid of
the console group also tied for second
at 18% stop clapping
80% Oh both your favorite and the
competition problem-solve group shallow
4th place at only 3% listen up my
console never disappoints me so the
people do not agree with the lower class
episode what do the Lord's think about
this I'll start with low K what just say
either only competition or get rid of
that loser who's not performing
we're not keeping my weight up no you
gotta accept what you have right like
you can always I you bought the product
you want better yeah
request better ask for better now at the
same time you can't make direct
comparisons like look what they got I
need that like no just go get that over
there that's it you have the right to
ask for but at the same time don't
you're limiting yourself if what you
want is someplace else then get that as
well or trade up I feel about the
argument that they're going against the
Lord's cuz not just you um is that on
there saying well you have to keep them
in better cuz otherwise things don't
change like don't let them off the hook
stay on them you know you're the
consumer so I'm actually a 1 4 we start
off your show real quickly home I want
to start off on a serious tone I just
want to UM pay respects to a fallen Lord
in our gaming community a lord who
served his country and that's Matt aka
Xbox addict not not alright Xbox there
was some confusion and I had a guy hit
up a couple times I'm like no he's OK he
was asking but no seriousness you know I
really had a chance to UM cross paths
with them at two different fan fests he
was always very positive and respectful
to me also had like one of the most
amazing gaming collections not kidding
like almost like mr. high level so like
if we check out his Twitter page it
wasn't just Xbox he was a serious retro
collector true gamer at heart definitely
proud of the entire gaming community
even Phil Spencer all the Microsoft
decks with changing in room you know
their avatars on Twitter to gaming
addict Xbox addict and um you know as
well as other console gaming from you
know PlayStation or whatever so just
show the show put aside that you know
the petty console war differences not
nonsense the honored Lord Mac you know
I'm saying and put that with the avatars
and just shows how much he was loved to
miss so I know there's a go fund me up
off for the family and a wife and he
left some some really beautiful children
behind the link is in the description so
um I lost salute to him you know and
like I said please and we would miss you
bro and like I said we just want to pay
our respects as a fellow Lord so that's
what we got and we're gonna get into the
show now so what we are all here for
later like the launch of the masterpiece
on 420 the Nintendo Lambo was released
discussion I'm not even engaging in that
[Laughter]
God of War talk y'all so we're gonna
break this thing down you know obviously
the Lords have played it almost love
playing we're all in different stages um
I'm assuming me King is at the more at
the beginning I'm like right after him
then I believe sovereign is further
along and then Lord Act is actually
finished
katsu is so much so first we're gonna
get down with the arm honest non
spoilery impressions that we can give so
far in the second part we're gonna talk
about the media and the media bias
aspects of us what's going on if there's
media by Erasmus what's going on we're
getting to that but let's just start now
with our honest and pressure so let's
start from the beginning
you know actually actually I can always
do it this way let's do it this way cuz
King let's start with a tit addict you
have seen you've done it all what you're
honest impressions non spoilery of God
of War mm-hmm it's a good game it's war
it's I think it's the best game this
came out on the PlayStation platform
this gen oh okay
by far okay so again now as far as what
prior to god of war on PlayStation what
had the title personally for you
blood-borne I really enjoyed on toad on
- okay no I played like the first stage
or Ratchet and Clank Anna and I turned
it off I'm going to get back to the Last
of Us because I do want to play that
I've just got so much stuff going on I
don't intend on plan on charger but now
someone's challenged me $200 to beat an
uncharted 4 on the hardest difficulty so
I'm gonna have to just take that out and
play Uncharted 4 mm-hm that's pretty
much about all my question to you is
what makes it the best in your opinion
what are the key factors for units like
y'all this this is why I like this is
why god wars that way when it comes to
hold it let me take off this other
earphone mm-hmm sorry I was playing God
war Wow button smashing other way no I
started one fighting the Valkyrie
looking things they and I started in a
and you know I started when you got
started the the holes woods the hosts
combats we all right now I literally did
like an entire temple in that 20 minutes
but when it comes to the everyone in
this chat you see me on Planet X Box you
see me on ILP from the start I've said I
won't fill this new God of War I you
were the against it in just the way that
you know the Cabaret go because I felt
like it was gonna last of us and let's
be real here they did last of us this
game you know they put it in the
hardcore story orientated there's no you
know there's a reason that he has a kid
now is because they they would around
that kind of you know having another
player well not you necessarily a player
but an AI that's around that you can
build some kind of core relationship
with they've done this for the past
couple games now unchartered to my
understanding you have someone with you
at almost all times so they did that on
this and at first off I didn't like the
kid when I was seeing him I was like
this kid is annoying he's gonna be very
frustrating I'm not trying to have
another Ashley moment from Resident
played the game is nothing like that
they they have a good balance I did feel
like the game was that Kratos felt
really clunky at the beginning of the
game it won't like a generic souls game
at the start okay but after you unlock
abilities and everything he started to
balancing out and you started filling
like Kratos they took the essence of the
older god wars I didn't think they'd be
able to do it to a point they did they
got the atmosphere what they like stuff
like puzzles like pretty much every
puzzle in this game it's just throwing
an axe at something and freezing some
kind of coil that's all I did I didn't
like that I didn't like the fact that
the troll that will they literally
showed you at e3 you fight that thing
like 15 times
on the floors I gotta sell separate
segments for that so I just want you to
focus on the positive I just want you to
focus on its what it is amazing um when
I played it I was like I don't
understand how you know we'll go into
the the whole puzzle mechanics and stuff
I don't understand how they are going to
make this game feel like God a war with
that Last of Us thing especially but
then I played it and at the end of the
game I was like oh that's how they did
it right you were like how are they
gonna implement the core mechanics of
the older god Awards into this style
that they've chosen right that was your
main concern around this PK dude I don't
care about that I don't care about the
Lord there's no reason to have the same
12 15 times of different colors take the
Poseidon fight from God of War 3 mm that
was an epic moment in god award three
that was the first 10 minutes they did
that same thing here with the stranger
of not really gonna go into any of that
they took that hype that you have when
you fight Poseidon in God War 3 they
enhance that and they kept it the whole
game shoutout to BK best I said addict
read the Lord there's a reason the
trolls are you dressed in oh when I
bring stuff up there and you know people
come at me they're like oh you know and
what's funny is like some of the
especially the PlayStation fanboys you
can't say anything negative like not
even a little bit you know I save just
like you know there's too many trolls to
have the same thing they cut me out on
Twitter it's like look man like I'm
height for this game and then I got
attacked for making a post on Twitter
saying that I'm still height for stay to
decay to people really attacking me
saying they were tweeting me they're
like addicts sitting here hyping I you
know
is the the the crumb shot on Planet Xbox
that on the part of I sitting there all
addict you're crazy you know you should
only be height for God a war pretty much
I'm like you guys are like ridiculous
I will first off I'll play anything I
want to I am still hype for stadium K to
it you know I you know I'm at I got
attacked on Lucas podcast cuz I said as
much as I enjoy God award and I do I
loved every moment of it I don't play
games
like I play God of War very often
I still like breath of the wild we go
get to you and the reason for that is I
went into this expecting the worst like
I really did like I went into this like
you know this is it's gonna feel clunky
especially when they showed more stuff I
went into it breath of the wild as you
know we wanted this a you know there
were skeptics including myself with this
game yeah but if you look first off the
both of them clear clearly nostalgic
both of them but Zelda like I said when
we were mentioning the foremost
inspiration games God war wasn't on that
list so it was up next your opinion
first of all you how far you and what
what are your impressions of it so far I
can't really tell how far I am it's huge
but um how many hours is just saying
like how many hours you think about I
don't think they tell you I know I mean
I've been playing since basically
Wednesday but you know III try to get
all the side stuff that I can write so
you're playing like me well you're
really being very intricate with
collecting rules and trying to find the
different what is it hack Silver's
yeah hack Silver's are like you have um
like like like there's something like
birds and stuff like collectible stuff
you know oh and stuff off to the side
that you don't have to do and then stuff
that's probably too difficult early on
in the game which you'll find out real
quick to leave alone it can't come back
ya know but I'm at the point where I've
seen like a couple of Oh ash moments to
tell you okay this game is much bigger
than what I assumed it was gonna be mmm
you know you know how like when you
watch movie trailers and you hear the
movie trailer guy like in a world where
the world
yeah this game is that like it is an
epic story I guess huge it's human I
think that impresses me most about the
game besides like the overall production
value system everywhere you go is
different I guess everywhere there's so
many different looking vistas and like
they really crafted each and every part
of this game they like they it really
created their own version of Norse lore
like a the love and care that went into
this game is evident from jump for the
jump so that impressed me about it right
and the fact that Kratos in the
beginning see a lot of things with
cradles the the argument cradles say
he's one note one note but he's a more
subdued one note right like different
like um and to be honest like and you
have to keep playing the game to see
more because in the beginning it's just
boy this boy this annoyed with him and
then as the kid as the kid progresses
you see that the kid is more willing to
engage him like nah man you're dead
wrong about this you see that the kid
becomes more defiant hmm and he pushes
cradles to have to open up a little bit
more it's a very slow burn to that like
and I think he's the same and cuz I
wondered like what people talk about
like wow he cradles his deep like he's
layered now and then when you're playing
you're like nah he's he doesn't seem
layered he just seems different like
he's he's kind of a broken Mickey he
really is like I didn't want to stress
that this is the same Kratos that we
that you know we loved from the other
kata Wars mm-hmm but it's pretty much
like it's legitly a broken Kratos like
hatred man he hates everything but
pretty much like the only thing that he
even stands as his son and half the time
you don't even stay in his eyes but that
doe if y'all look at the games he was
never for he loved his family he hated
what happened to his family he was
tortured by the gods because the gods
lied to him so that's where his hatred
towards the gods came from so I mean I
didn't I will let solver finish and then
I'm gonna get at you
and that's to Kings Point right I think
what this game does perfectly is that it
brings him to another point in his life
this is this is in all respects a sequel
as much as it is a reboot of the game
like it is a CD it is rebooting it but
it was it's definitely see it is that
same cradles with all of that stuff that
he's endured weighing on him now and now
him having the opportunity to sort of
fix that a little bit and and sort of
make up for his errors a little bit and
he doesn't know how to do it the crazy
thing is like what I see is that kratos
with all the daddy issues he's had like
you don't say the big-time daddy issues
he's not a bad father per se he just
doesn't know how to be a father
overbearing father um a lot of things
that he would he was doing I saw some
hilarity in a lot of things that he does
know because the expectations that he's
trying to build a man and he doesn't
understand that you have to love to
build man exactly the tender part is the
wife to do that look at the end of the
day like you know we might be in a
different region but he was still raised
as as a Spartan like they weren't raised
like that they were put to the fire they
would literally kill them like any kind
of okay listen don't think Spartans a
nice people they can't go you know he
wanted to put his hand on a little kid
ya know love you get out there you
tackle that Duke took his bow
dear listen to me just a little aw stop
and finish and I'm gonna get to it
I don't want to overstep just call me
Weston so I mean for me the game it just
does it from combat to to the setting to
just basically their production values
the stories opening up more and more
I've seen people say that the writing is
better than last of us I don't know I
haven't gotten that yet I would say it
improves it's just such a complete
product like it's hard to find for this
folks with it don't question is not a
perfect game by any means but to bring
cradles back in this way and to make him
relevant
today um and to give him to make you
force you to have to be with him the
whole time right no cinematix no nothing
just straight up on Kratos and to make
him make you want to be there is it's a
special thing it's a special game
through and through
we don't get games like this very often
with this attention to detail we did at
the end of the day you know we're about
to let king go at the end of the day I
don't want like I hate when people use
the word like perfect first off this
game's not a 10 out of 10 by any means
chad is what you do it's an amazing game
it's a masterpiece
ten out of ten that's the road just a
subjective thing but what I want to
point out what they did I don't want to
point out like you know any kind of
negative things they did there because
there's a few I want to point out that
this how you successfully bring an old
franchise into the new age
okay look King you are right now I'm
just gonna do we're gonna be very sure
okay we do the positives you know what
what would impress you that give overall
impressions yeah all right so um let me
start off by saying that my time
allocated to such the game was in all
that you know crazy um the game came out
I could have got it the day before I had
9 p.m.
like everybody else but I work at night
and I really didn't care to get it like
um I waited til he opened in the morning
and I picked up the game and I picked up
the game I went and I threw it inside my
system and again PlayStation with a slow
loading craft I had to wait for that
right so I put it in and I was just like
hey you load up and I got on a pub gee
with death the me and death was just
like going at it and we had such a good
time and then I met like ten other
people and started this whole new
aggressive click and pop G them
remembered that Oh odwar loaded in he
didn't want to do this no I really did
um so I turn on my playstation and then
um I went to play and my battery was low
let's control the charge go get some
more plug G time control of the charge
and I went play the conversation up to
it's going to be longer than the actual
conversation about monkeys better than
God we got that I went I went to sleep I
went to sleep and then I got up and I
said let me play this god of war yeah it
is so this is my half hours later we
want to be clear like no acetone
exercise the whole next day later Oh
now we got on yeah I threw it on and I'm
like oh look nice graphics yeah I've
seen this in um zero horizon door cry
alright alright I'm waiting for this
this new graph for kicking the door and
attack me right sorry okay
I like atmosphere looks nice the detail
on cradles looks nice so he's throwing
ax he got y'all but younger because
that's Thor's axe if y'all don't know
Thor has an axe that does that alright
um and then you know the building and it
became very evident early as soon as I
picked up the controller this wasn't God
of War mm it became very evident but
we're talking about positives and so I'm
gonna keep it on a positive because I'm
going to go in on you 10 lovers mm-hmm
you guys that you have other games that
are really like higher scores and tens
you know but it's a very very damn good
game is it God of War I don't think so
but I'm keep the positives this is the
score fantastic um the the the 4k I'm
not gonna say checkerboard now am I
gonna do that to you um the 4k looks
very good um very sharp
he's very the controls on him is very
tight he's not as clunky as I thought he
would be with the over-the-shoulder view
the use of the little boy he's very
intricate like addict says the little
boy actually is useful kid is more
useful than crazy I've killed
I kill the enemies with just him wow
he's really kind of busted because he
has he has many arrows you want and once
you love that was my thought in because
I noticed that he had three arrows in
his quiver but he never stopped
unloading um but
we'll talk about the positive right so
the game looks good
it plays tight it sounds great I'm
having a sound yeah so the sound of the
game is God of War if you can really
take one aspect of that game and see
does it fall all the way back and I want
y'all to hit those legs because I see 40
before and only got 23 please like this
um it sound they captured that sound of
god oh god of war sound was as big as
its game plan graphics so do I believe
there's a sound so far is outpacing the
rest of the game yes
is it true to form yes the graphics is
very high up there um is it at all let's
get ya got me tip my tongue what and
explode oh sorry so sorry let me get two
by segments if King is finished in did I
let you let me go there we go cuz my
perspective is different
um god water me I'm gonna get killed
from my next statement but I gotta keep
it true at the round table God a war
from me is really not it was always a
solid franchise but he's never been a
franchise I really was passionate about
I remember playing a couple of other the
other game sparingly I remember buying a
fetal one you know I mean and don't get
me wrong it was epic but it's kind of
like what what sovereign said well he
was always one note to me and like he
just didn't do it for me it just that
style of game just didn't do it for me
so when they made the switch and I saw
the trailers and you know what AK was
there when I we know we shot a little
whiskey we watching it I'm just like
this is the God of War for me you don't
saying like just that the over the
shoulder joint you know the the more
cinematic storytelling kind of a feel
you know I mean so it shot up the Lord
Aaron summers in the chat saying that's
how am I feeling was I was never really
interesting on one to this one so when I
saw it I'm okay so now you know it's
come release time the game starts off
like okay now I'm just gonna keep it a
thousand and I know I'm gonna get killed
by Lord King and addict buddies in my
opinion right and Shaffers will shout
out the loss solve get your TVs together
my was together my TV was not to get I
had the technical lord I called him up
because I had this issue with hell-blade
and I had this issue with God war when I
was playing it and I got like a cast
what is it eight forty eight thousand
what was a thousand HD okay you know
mid-tier HD or 4k kind of situation and
I remember playing hell-blade and I
remember when sue knew I would rotate
the camera around her they'd be these
little artifacts were like yeah dust
mites on us like take pig pen I don't
like these dust mite and I remember
shout out to my boy dealer gaming he was
saying you know hell-blade on the X is
the best looking game on the x period
but I'm like not in my house that great
don't say shout out the Lord kibosh I'm
sitting I'm like what is it so I didn't
pay it no mind
until God war came I got the God of War
and I was like okay it looked good but
then lo Atreus came on the street and I
saw the dust mites on his head and I
said no pause the game I caught more
technical rust said no sovereign you
have to get at me with my TV setting
something is wrong because everybody
can't be saying this game looks like the
most greatest thing and on my TV you
don't so he went through the settings
come to find out I had some stupid HDR
simulating mode on I should have been
off without my settings right palm do it
back on good ROI but let me tell you're
almost blasphemous I don't care when the
kill that 2160p checkerboarding whatever
it's doing in my opinion prior to this
moment
Ryse son of Rome had the title for
character models face details that day
is over
we are now at a new weight when I see
Kratos his skin that when he hugged the
tree that's all I needed to see when the
game continued and as it continued to
play and I can seem to see things now
you may say okay there may be some frame
pacing issues you know shock a headlock
I bounced on the back of my head when he
goes into the sprint I get it
you know if you plan on performance more
okay fine I get it but character model
I've played it all assassins chaos queen
origin
I've played um almost overjoyed I've got
the gears for or they cannot touch
Kratos I'm sorry that is over this is
the greatest admire that is oh this is
the greatest I don't know how they're
doing it but it's so great I'm like I'm
like oh this is this has got to be full
motions like I don't know how they're
doing shoutout to Sony Santa Monica I
just can't believe that they're now as
far as the game itself I'm not that far
on maybe about five six hours okay all
I'm going to say in reference to what
I've played so far if you have not
gotten to the stranger in the opening
sections of the game all I'm gonna say
non spoilers is that that part in my
opinion is better than a lot of classic
games and bosses no I'm not saying okay
yeah I'm actually fine the Dockery okay
cool go get that part right dear I was
okay this is how you're doing the first
hour it this is what we okay I see the
smack in the mouth so to meet a goal it
was laid down at that point I still got
a lot to do
I still see certain low you know puzzle
elements I hear what you're saying I as
far as you know the puzzle stuff I I get
that you know saying and as I get on I
have to judge it more in its entirety as
a game of your candidate it's too early
for me to say any type of hyperbole like
that
all I will say is shouted not me and
Louis summers in the chat wrapper you
know say the fight with the stranger but
it's like for fresh from a graphical
standpoint to me it's undeniable that
the title has been given the bar has
been raised
they're doing this with less tech and it
looked better
i'ma say look better anything on Xbox
one X I'm sorry come for me at me some
blue you can see something else I'm not
now let's get to the floors can you do
that you know I'm hearing all this you
know what I'm not dude I didn't like
Michael Jordan imma give you a right I
didn't like Michael Jordan I'm outta my
fan I'm on a bandwagon hugger so all you
dudes out there you know to follow that
wave that dude oh he's that dude I'm out
of Steph Curry love thanks all right but
what I do love I love excellent so yes I
do love LeBron James and he gets it in
so I want you to understand a couple of
things my I'm a Scottie Pippen fan I'm
at hard work dude all right there's
other games on that system that are
actually they own that's not God of War
let's clear that up right there that
crap that you doing that's Thor the
story of Thor we talked about fantastic
graphics well given that Ricky Lee
Stevens
you got fantastic graphics I'm going
into the floors now being nice boy my
boy since I had to hear that over 400
times since I booted up the game boy boy
got annoying boy oh my god um it's not
God war I know what they did
that game was something else and it was
like you know what let's slap dog
warning into the cell um the media bias
touch this thing we'll get to that part
but let's get to these floors let's get
to these floors all right now I once got
a lot of stuff but you don't know who
Red Bear Thor is Norse mythology but
you're gonna talk to the wrong person
stop it get out of your feelings and get
into the game out of your feelings into
the game all right let me tell you a
couple of things where that game could
be any other game but God of War and it
would be it will still be nice but would
it rate is high no it wouldn't would it
capture the cry no it wouldn't
it's very cinematic it's very good to
show there's a very good game to stream
see what they're doing now is they're
going to games where it presents well
that game presents the best audience
system I swears no life it presents
better than 0 horizon north and 0
horizon going to me looks better than
that and I'm gonna get funky with you
because it's open-world from the GZA I
can see a mountain over there and I can
go there hmm where that mountain I can
do in a God of War where you go from
channel 4 the chamber it's up world
right completely keep it 100% funky if
you use all your graphics all in one
room - no let's be really nice
they're worried about rise we talking
about rise we talking about the Chen's
this game that hits Rock intense rise
didn't get tense coming out well right
[ __ ] I got chance coming out but we're
gonna talk about this game that's rockin
these numbers these numbers that these
are bamboozled numbers
fools go listen is it an 8.5 yeah is it
in some circles a nine but for you that
person has been waiting for this it's a
ten for you now you got fanboys that
want to sit there and say you don't have
this game on your system I have the game
on my god a GaN system because I got the
system
I don't limit myself so I'm not gonna go
blue the hyperbole I'm gonna give you a
hundred percent real I just told you
breath of the wild on an inferior system
here's a better game to me art wise it
can't hold a candle to that game alright
it cannot hold a candle you haven't seen
you ever seen a lot though can you have
it I'm telling you that God of War
graphically destroys that game oh I'm
not telling you I'm talking about the
art direction stuff you're saying like I
play I play no no no I know it's gonna
look beautiful III purposely crafted not
about how they look necessarily I'm
talking bout the world they're crafted
like in terms of like atmosphere right
exactly
the atmosphere is beautiful I'm loving
the atmosphere I'm loving the game so
far but the hyperbole I'm not buying
into because it's not got a war I've
never had to cut you he said God would
he's been outside 88.5 he's three hours
in he said it hasn't grabbed him like
horizon zero dawn the beginning is
definitely a slow burn
definitely a slow burn it's a brief bird
I went to sleep did you get to the
streams I'm gonna play the game okay to
finish the game hmm
I'm just letting you know that does the
game have it's not God of War it has
flaws it's a very you know I swear I'm
not taking nothing away from the
PlayStation exclusive and this is your
moment this is your moment stand up
there and yell from the top highest peak
you can do it but I want you to do this
right I want you to do this you little
PlayStation buggers oh I want you to do
this I want you to talk I want you to do
this
mm-hmm take that because you're gonna
remake that game over again play it
again put that game on Oh jump in fit no
say what you gonna say then you know one
thing one thing I have to disagree it
just seems that King is in part
criticizing the game for what it's not
and not for the game that's their right
no just like you said it's not gonna if
it didn't have the God of War name and
was the exact same game does it get
tense
probably not it'll get 99.5 maybe it's
not getting tense because it's a brand
new whatever it's a brand new IP it's
not got a war right I think part of what
brings it to you know whatever the
people consider a 10 or whatever
masterpiece is the fact that they were
able to take Kratos
from one aspect in his life that he was
totally different and bring him to
another point in his life where his
where he's different and it it makes
sense so you bring you bring this
character back back to relevance right
so for me like that's where the whole
package comes in right lady we're able
to take this whole franchise that was
something completely different in my
opinion move it forward make it relevant
and still make it look up to me he says
it's not got a war like about to cut
yourself a mess I say I need this same
kind of energy with crack that three
comes out energy a little bit sooner
when arms state of decay comes out I
want you to have that energy when we got
four players playing but you can't get a
networked bone I want you to have that
same kind of energy are we doing going
through the houses and you can't play
that I want you to have that same kind
of energy when that game comes out
because right now your energy is high
and you're single yeah the corner can we
play with you can I join you
no I cannot so when you just bring it
down a little bit bro
bring it down just right now you all the
way up here in a closet by yourself I
can show you a room there you can play
by yourself over there when I'm playing
with my friends whole players when we
getting busy if you're looking over
there with your PlayStation hey talking
about Oh how's that state of decay door
is doing sweet well is going swell swell
starting a fire you guys keep that when
you playing alone in the corner boy boy
control boy
automatically you splash then you slash
your joint down to a seven all for the
fact that you got to play by yourself
cut it out you hype because you only got
one input lag negative clearance the
water the water doesn't look great and I
don't understand why like the water does
it use all the textures on his back
there's one thing I'm missing the two
Cognito right the game model when you go
into the menu the model they're using
the menu is more ridiculous than the
in-game model
as the great as far as character mazi
the pinnacle of graphics on advocate um
I said the water thing is weird at cuz
it's just it doesn't compare to the rest
of the game in terms of looks um I agree
with adequate the trolls cuz the trolls
I'ma be honest like I cheese a lot so
far the ones that I faced I just use
them with it with at Reyes and an axe
throws like there's no unlike some other
fights with running down throw the axe
continue that to me they could have been
those fights could have been more in
depth there's there are other people you
fight yeah you know I will say one thing
there is a time in the game where you go
and you know you think you're about to
fight a big dude you think you're about
to do some crazy [ __ ] you get there to
troll Lorelei's is saying that's why
they supposed to be doing okay what
about anything like people sitting there
like people on Planet X Marcoux you
fought minotaurs how many times of guard
walk that's 15 years ago could we not
evolve like that chase everything about
God a war but the M the amount of the
fact that they have the law around them
and they each supposed to have like a
different type of personality in the
reasons that they're there and they
don't talk the ladies in the realm must
be represented
absolutely no doubt the lavash had to
look in the chat much appreciated
continue solve and then we move
so that um the cop the combats fantastic
to me but it takes a while to like when
you when you first turn the game on and
you just go into the settings and you
look at like the controller layout
you're like wow that's not much to this
right it's not much to it at all and in
the beginning that's why you could it
can sometimes feel like it's a slot cuz
like it doesn't have much now the game
progresses and you open up stuff and
they made it into like a mini RPG like
you have all your stuff has stats like
you know your weapons your weapons have
different you know properties you know
your armor all that stuff it's like a
mini RPG so um and that's a little bit
convoluted - I wish they were clearer
about how that stuff works cuz you just
have to sort of figure that out on your
own if you're not very clear like how to
slot this stuff what this means and
stuff like that isn't that like a
glaring flaw yo your hate they got the
championship and the team they play got
disqualified before the game even
started you don't have a multiplayer you
bought it but a kid with no friends
I hate he said his jealousy jealous like
the trolls
um what any other start it's like I said
like the mechanics gonna come to any
kind of puzzles pretty much the exact
same puzzle over and over again like man
there's a couple things that I'm like
about the overall story I can't really
go into that way like when you got the
trolled over 13 she's going
I said about the troll-like people
someone tell me in the chat since you
are so enlightened about this lore and
you've been so raised on this lore why
is there such a different color trolls
in this thing why do I go from fighting
one and then 20 minutes later fight a
green one troll addict they have
different abilities you know why because
they thought the death scene was so nice
they led you to recreate it you know
like I don't think this is a spoil but I
don't understand like they don't really
go into between the third and this one
like ever like at all like I want to
know how Kratos lived from that big
blade be shoved through his stomach he's
a demigod but he's gonna live forever
that's another thing that's like again
that's why it makes it this it makes it
he's gonna live forever enlist is a game
over screen gotcha but this is the thing
like with cradles he has to hold all
that stuff that he's done he can never
escape that everything in the old in the
old games right the in the beginning
like he did what he did and then he had
nightmares about it all the time right
so his goal was player so all of that
like he had he had nightmares that he
couldn't get rid of right so that was
like his first impetus to kill gods
right when he got rid of the nightmares
the fact of the matter is that he still
had the memories like he still knew
knows what he did so that field is
raised to kill everybody including his
dad so all like he is a at the end of
God of War 3 he had like a little bit of
a moment where he realized no I can't
let this happen because I've caused this
chaos you have to try to find a way it
was when Poseidon was about to kill
herself at the end of 3 yeah he was
pretty much like anyone that says a
spoiler in the comment section go do
something
I got a disqualify your
[Laughter]
it's like I said like I understand
people like me are you gonna compare
mini-bosses to main bosses what's like
it'd be different if they like don't get
this fool
you know that epic fight that you have
in the stranger that's not all the time
okay fighting an epic fight which is
only like maybe five of them you're
fighting a damn troll with a damn slab
on his head some teleport all I'm gonna
say that we gotta compare it to other
games in its own class right in its own
have you played that game I have not I'm
still not strong play that game and
you're gonna hide that game you're gonna
put it higher than that game well that's
what lost Incan lost ingot just said
that he's still at three hours in and he
said he it hasn't captured him - we are
small the game is very slow going right
the lady lost she's killing the chat
that's my feeling is the way she feels
is that I still feel the stranger set to
tone though kind of a false tone we see
this is where I'm getting matches like
the end of the day is like what other
games the game comes packaged with and
we're gonna compare it let's go apples
to apples the one player game is dead
then they go in or Phil because he would
say as far as you know he say one play
game was dead but no
it's not as relevant if it was too much
you know it's true let's keep that same
energy somebody's desk energy let's keep
that same energy for this game that is a
single play experience it's a solo game
yeah triggering again he's in full
position to come back addict beat the
game all right
you know what's crazy you in the
comments I was all alive I was online
with him and I saw him on I saw him I
saw him because it says he's on right
and I was trying to join his game you a
savage from a single player standpoint
in my opinion if you ain't gotta compare
apples to apples it's doing things that
I've never seen a single player genre do
and in stuff that people have attempted
they've done it better so that's just
where I'm at as far as the floors yes
they are they're definitely floors I see
what you guys are talking about as far
as some of the enemies and stuff like
that repetitiveness you know I might be
nitpicking you know like but at the end
of the day like my nitpicking is far
outweighed over the pauses of the gasps
that's all I'm saying now the last
question this is really can only add the
answer which is obviously it's 2018 it's
early you know I'm saying you the only
person here that had finished it you
know from what you've played is this
game of the year status was monster
honor I do think this took monster on
and coming from attic that is HUGE
now let's get over to the next part of
this which is the media stuff so
obviously there's two parts to this I'm
going like low King set it off to which
is arm
okay first shout out to all Lord just
Gordon he had all put out a tweet in
Port Gus kind of said Twitter on fire
what the Cognito he's the only reason I
played
mommy laughing last Ohio pretty much you
know Lord just what he said you know
they set on fire apparently there was
something on the IGN on social media
page it was on I actually was on
Instagram and it was on Facebook and it
was the classic you know this is how you
know got a poor looks on PlayStation and
this is how God works an Xbox one it was
a complete troll you know kind of stuff
and it was surprising you know saying so
just go and he put the tweet out and
just said I'm very you know upset kind
of disappointed but I Jen with this that
said Twitter ablaze on Mike Ibarra got
contacted on it just went on and on
until they finally got to Ryan McCaffrey
and Peter Schneider who are jumped in
front of it and they actually made a
formal apology to Xbox the Xbox fans the
Xbox community and stuff like that so I
want to turn this to the Lord's on two
fronts one we seeing obviously that
thing from you know the medium
standpoint we've seen that um actually
ending up the flipside to is a Mike
Ibarra just recently um I guess he did a
poll and he was like okay because my
gonna Mike's active in these gaming
streets right
Mike's planes right so he actually had
another poll which was kind of like um
hey which gained he want me stream and
he actually put God of War in the list
and without surprise got a war one so
when that was the game that he was gonna
stream you know a lot of the Xbox
community didn't like that you know they
were like you know what are you doing
and this is why we're losing you to that
kind of a rhetoric so two-part one do we
think there's a media bias with this
whole situation based on the IGN fiasco
and - is it okay for a person like
Maggie Barra
to be playing Lord King I need you up on
this alright let's let's get to the
genesis of it
technically PlayStation was dead set up
to murder them and put them away and I'm
gonna say we because my blood is green
I'm funky like if I have to trace to go
inside the store and buy Xbox one for a
Playstation that's bleed
every day of the week I'm gonna do that
that's your problem the dawn the dawn
the dawn fumbled the ball he had to just
go over the goal line and just finish
you guys off the bottom line your guys
was in the red money wasn't good your
money looked funny and a light towards
each lack the black liner for the $10
donation thank you so much look that was
love and I'm gonna show you exactly why
you this is what your $10 brought let me
give it to you it was over it was over
for the Playstations ponies it was done
it was a rat it was it was old until the
TV comment came out and they ran with
the rhetoric and they did and I said
yeah watch won't be down fumble a layup
I saw him patrick huen it he's getting
me dirty he did me so dirty
thank Phil Phil is here did you get that
thanks Phil Phil is here all those dudes
that knew the impending death was coming
think about it this way if I do the
standing over you wear that axe and he
slips and he falls and he cuts his own
head off killed yourself and now that
dude that was about to die is running
that's the PlayStation he's running all
over the place
those IDs that you get now what I never
came out would have been over for you
but networking and now he's doing your
thing they shout out to PlayStation food
its thing I don't need you
i buy you I buy you because games are
there and I love games the bias comes
from the fact that that was about to die
now you're rubbing it in our face we're
alive and we do it better because of
your idiocy
you know stability has allowed me to
spread like a cancer all over the place
you guys are shouting from the tops of
the mountain on how and adequate our
first party games are your change the
goal
every time you don't have Indies oh we
got to end these now you don't have
first party
yeah I don't have multiplayer y'all
don't have exclusive they'll change the
gold line every time and every media is
going with this crap yep they're making
short and this was the most egregious
one when he said oh god a war on
PlayStation got a war xbox it was a
black screen well I'm gonna do the same
exact thing I'm gonna put out the same
exact tweet and I'm gonna do it in
Reverse with state of decay beta decay
on xbox and state of decay - on
PlayStation mmm because even if it did
come out on y'all anyway I can't play
with nobody on are you happy when you
put your information and nobody's
talking about the security defects in
Playstation nobody's luck the problems
that go on there he said hey y'all
complaining about media bias when
everybody loved Xbox 360s now you're
crying
rivers I'm letting you know are you safe
with your PlayStation PSN information
online right now it's a public now you
worry every time you swipe your credit
card there's some dude in the Ukraine
didn't spy God with Joe dollars so let's
keep that funky no media bias he said I
GM made light of titanfall being
exclusive and PSN being down when he
said there's no media bias there's no
media bias Brett right we mean you
understand the truth for the fact that a
matter is that Microsoft gets killed ten
times more than anything that happens
with PlayStation that's where media bias
is media bias is if the person the same
dude each person does the same thing one
person gets killed for it more than the
other person there's a bias towards that
person that didn't get murdered as much
as the first person bucks cannot get
away with half of the stuff PlayStation
does go look at look at something as
simple as when it comes to you know
being extremely consumer friendly
Microsoft would have to stuff that the
sony has it would still be having
articles talked about it now as far as
Mike Ibarra playing the PlayStation game
good he's a game and he should he should
not be beholden to just play on this
system because he works for the company
on his off time whatever he does on his
off time he should be able to do happily
he asked the people the people chose and
he's engaging with his community his
these people because if Microsoft
decides to fire him tomorrow does he
stop being Mike Ibarra mmm does he stop
being the person that you talk to right
oh are you just talking to him because
he works for Microsoft no I tweet at him
and I talk because he's part of the
community and he actually really engages
I play destiny with him the man is
saying that he wants to play God of War
why are we attacking a gamer what what
about the people who say that as a
executive for Microsoft you shouldn't be
promoting playing the competition's game
in that that stupid business wise it's
stupid if it's not in the language of
his contract if then his contract is
this you cannot publicly admit to liking
the competition which Phil tells
everybody all the time because Bill is a
new thing maybe in another pass that
they wouldn't say that we play that but
in Phil's regime they're gamers there
the game is there now I want to back you
up one thing because Brad made a good
point I don't want to don't oversight
him um he said made two points he said
one he said Microsoft this is back to
the media biased in America he said my
son was getting killed because their
product isn't as good
he said the also media killed Sony for
not offering cross-play media killed Jim
Ryan Sony an so what he's trying to say
is that it's performance he's trying to
say that if Microsoft was performing
better then they wouldn't get killed
do you agree with this okay that's also
a valid point as well do I want them to
perform better in certain aspects yeah
would I what I believe they would get
the credit if they did perform better no
I I don't think they would get the
credit I mean something is simple
IGN I don't know who here saw it IGN did
a they did a list they'd like the top
five of the most hyped games and for
some reason you know maybe this person
that made the list was more excited
about it but he put the PC version of
state of decay - and not the xbox
version like let's be real here people
that review this game at IGN do you
honestly think they're going to review
the Windows 10 version oh it's not gonna
be as many clicks you want you review
that I guarantee you yeah at the other
day they did like they do it out of
spite now they don't do it because of
bias they do it because you must be real
here so here's the question he added do
you feel as a whole I gin as an entire
media organization has a bias towards
Xbox no I I think they want to make
money and they do whatever is clique so
you think this is a clickbait initially
this is you think this is by everyone or
these media outlets or specific people
like that have personal biases and like
when brad says there's no beating me
about media bias he means as an entity
like media outlets as entities can't
have bias because they you know they're
they're professionals mean neutral not
claim time that you gotta remember these
guys they're not just journalists
anymore right each individual is a
person they're gonna have their personal
preference right and now they're not
just writing articles and they're not
just writing reviews now they're on
camera all the time now their
personalities right we're not just a
blank face that you don't know like you
know and then they have their own
personal you know like whatever Twitter
accounts or whatever so now you had a
balance your professional life which are
with your private life it's very very
blurry line right so I'm sure whoever
put up this thing I'm sure it's an it's
a younger person at eyes line it's not
an older person right and let's be clear
let's be clear this was the social media
team not the editorial team it was
absolutely continued but it's just that
thing where it's like you know at you're
gonna have ended
giuls having their own opinions that's
just the way it is and a lot of that
stuff's gonna seep out because the fact
of the matter is it that I wanna I want
to say something real quick you go for
uh if I remember correctly didn't Ryan
McCaffrey say people at IGN are playing
steady K on Xbox one axes wasn't that
his exact words honestly that what doing
a PC bill during the first nineteen
first they say we're playing a PC bill I
do remember his Lord looked over saying
that part it should not at PAX we played
it on Xbox one x you know we see was up
a good kisser it's kind of how you're
gonna see it because all of these people
are gonna have the individual opinions
and a stuff's gonna seep out and even in
the shows that are associated
specifically with their outlets like you
see it uh you know we've talked about
how Jason Schreyer like it just it just
it emanates from him that he's not the
biggest fan or my girl of let's do it
all right I've seen Brian altano like
he's like he'll play sorting stuff on
Xbox but you can tell where his
preferences are and it's fine as long as
when you when you talk about when you
talk about the other because Dad as you
as as a journalist that is your job to
just give this give the news right and
as a personality you're gonna give your
opinions on said news right now I'm with
you so I think I mean I'm not thinking
kind of falls along the lines you I
don't feel that there's this grand
conspiracy against icebox on that level
but I do feel that look at we're human
beings right we all have inherent biases
even myself like we all have it there's
certain things that you get you get
technical this is an Xbox park he's
right here's the thing the YouTube this
what I see like we can't that we can't
announce the fact that resolution gate
and that kind of stuff drove traffic
right during the beginning in a
generation
when Xbox games Xbox one X Games or Xbox
one game scuse me we're not hitting the
1080p mark and the Playstations were
right and they did those side comparison
I remember those articles you know I'm
saying I'm not trying to say that just
because they made the article that means
their boss gets Xbox but we
can't also deny the fact that these
things generate traffic this general
interest right so now I come to this
situation that way it's like okay this
is you know x1 care or and this is
Playstations that right is it immature
is it silly absolutely you know I'm
saying it's it's [ __ ] you know I
didn't take it that seriously I am glad
that just brought it to light though
because there is again there's people
who work in these organizations and
these outlets that are for the most part
their goal is supposed to be a neutral
media outlet right their goal is is
supposed to tell you this is what the
facts are and then you make an informed
decision based on the facts not okay
this is how your game looks on this
another game that system doesn't have it
do I feel that oh my god no Microsoft I
do agree with braaap in this sense that
yeah max will put a lot of themselves in
this situation their own selves because
of performance a lot of it is driven by
performance no doubt if you're not
putting out good product and you're not
putting out good services you are going
to get attacked for that however when
the narrative is continued and driven by
clicks and also you have situations like
you had like this which I've seen before
and other resolution articles and I
remember even a GameSpot article where
um they were asking at the time it was
actually a very intense order actually
sent to anchorman I can't believe that
GameSpot ran is which was like you know
the reasons why you should get an Xbox
one X and literally I mean Xbox one or
cos NX and literally like none of the
panel members on this panel gave any
reasons to get an Xbox one okay that's
their team but the one woman who said
yes you know I like it and I like it for
this I like it was the abs are like for
this she got attacked clowned and
ridiculed on the past girl and I'm just
like wow like this desert pinion and
she's giving why and and this is an
influencer this is kind of like the you
know I'm saying right so that that's the
only thing again I just feel that
there's certain
cific yeah psycho gaming knows what I'm
talking about shouted psycho yeah she
got laughed where she works she got
clown like literally the GameSpot entire
team destroyed her on this panel I was
completely shocked by that and I was
like wow they're putting this out you
know in the media like that this dish
was surprisingly so that that's pretty
much when I got on it and that's the
thing because you still if you're gonna
be commenting like that then you know
what leave get your own YouTube channel
and talk about whatever you want when
you're on a neutral outlet that you
can't just when I have a problem because
then at that point also you're still
you're still benefiting from the from
from the benefits of being a journalist
and getting your hands on the stuff
early cycle day I'm so glad because I
thought I remember that artic when he
knows I thought it was a joke I thought
I was gonna say I gotcha at the end they
were dancers and they ran this and I was
like wow that's completely
unprofessional
but that's what I got on any of the laws
windchime before we move move this thing
on Yahoo put it this way y'all gonna
like the pole kitchen I'm very curious
to see how the realm answers alright so
are we going to move on and obviously
there's been some shakin bacon as a
result as a result of it what stuff but
uh Microsoft in the news you know I'm
saying so apparently you know looks like
a videogames industry Darrell Gallagher
veteran has joined the Microsoft Studios
executive leadership team he's now the
head of Microsoft Studios which are I
mean head of Microsoft with my booty
announcing on Twitter this guy has a
long career he's been a square we call
you my pretty much a Gallagher man this
guy has a long career as a veteran in
the game he was
former head of Crystal Dynamics he
worked on a Tomb Raider reboot you know
riser to a sequel you know I want to
shout out Lord ring you know shut up
Rashad long ran out door he's got a
great video on this you know and his his
a penis is he thinks why um he thinks
Dow might be the one in charge of
running his own studio at Xbox I want to
bring this to the Lord you know that you
know it is so well but once you reach
this one box we'll just call him a
stranger is something Justice League do
you guys remember when Superman yeah in
the flesh it was that cinematic
experience that made you say oh [ __ ]
the correlations two good things because
hey Guido's you know what I wanted to do
yeah I wanted to play playing it oh my
god okay you know you have maybe but
that's what did it for me was a bad
movie there are scenes and just leave
that come it brings that it brings
something yeah but that fight scene was
something that I don't know if you guys
would agree but Sony as being a movie
studio they have the options to I mean
they they're just so talented in putting
a feeling type quality CNN that's one of
the reasons that they do so well and
I've gotten attacked it's not the reason
and Sony doesn't need to movie industry
to make even securing spider-man the
character until dawn was legitly yes
press conferences like you can tell that
they have an understanding of how to
present something I don't know if I told
you guys how I became Kratos I wasn't
even on Twitter hmm and that III came
and they were plan that orchestra music
yeah
yes I think that's dinner before last
it was 2016 so anyway once Kratos came
out the shadows that was I was done so
you know what they release it perfectly
off for 24 reason they wanted all strip
away the God of War or from the game yes
and Sony puts that game out let's say
let's say the story done Thor a red
beard let's say the story of red beard
right because this is a legend all right
um and yes John Barranca has this sort I
mean that hammer I mean oh yes they put
that game out does that game rate it is
the same exact game does it do
this rate as high without the God of War
attached to it he does and I'm gonna
tell you why right does I'm gonna talk a
guy strip away the first the first three
four or five games right if you want to
count ascension and all that stuff
strip away that right from the menu
screen in well now we're just talking
about a game we're not talking about the
story or anything like that that's just
from the graphics in the gameplay
standpoint the first thing when I came
on his podcast today the first thing
that we talked about was the stranger
that epic singing oh we didn't even talk
about the game but we just talked about
the scene being set up you're trucking
tell me you cannot tell me even if this
game was was was gears and that see what
that's like I just filled disc Kratos I
felt this that um when they attach god
of war name to the game and the game
essentially became god of war whatever
the concept was and he decided to go
with this oh they knew from a cachet
point because up until that point
god of war is probably the numbers with
excellence on the PlayStation I can't
really say that I played a God of War
game on the PlayStation and it was
mediocre to me yeah I will all of God
war games were up there in the 9th and
10th type of level you understand yes oh
yeah writings they have always win 94 93
and right right and I felt by them
attaching this name to the game that I
at this point don't feel like this is a
war yet to God and Lord addict made a
good point because he actually agree
with you looking like he felt from the
beginning stage he was like look it's
great but this is not God war you know
God correct me if I'm wrong when cuz you
finished it you
said this you're gonna get to a point
where it's God what is that [ __ ]
yes oh yeah those ones they spoil it for
you we all know this game has RPG
elements in it right yes you have to
your eyes you have to do certain things
you have to get build up your character
right
this game is progression so you start
off just trying to get to fill out the
games and then learn a few combos and
then before you know it towards the
middle to the end of the game you're
spot-on you're like [ __ ] this is God of
War for this is what we were looking for
is just a different version because this
is player of the next generations time
and it's a reboot this is a reboot this
is going to be a trilogy so yeah I
realize they're sent up that story and
then after this trilogy is over doing
the voted on that points off that's cool
but this is this is and I expect more
from my companies this is what Sony
saying right they say what we do best is
single-player story driven games this is
no limit to play in for multiplayer or
eliminate that because you're not
utilizing it and why am i paying $60 are
you
right you could say this and imma give
you this rice under bro and I'm glad you
went to our first release game because I
want you to understand one thing that
game released was something that this
game in year did not release with
multiplayer I want you if that game came
before okay and they have multiplayer in
the arena and I was able to join with my
friends and have fun because there's no
decapitations in here your people just
disappear in a puff of smoke where
that's that but let's keep that together
how come this game doesn't have
multiplayer and I demand more from this
company oh okay I'll give you that you
you demand more from Sony and from the
game I will give you that how about this
right you got the world's most powerful
console twice they got that money from
you for the same game I have high
expectations for Microsoft Xbox why
can't they give me a decent rated game
that would give me the same experience
God award watch the internet blew up
Xbox guys mad
one job they showed you information
about that it's a civil war the the
whole H wants to be in a chaos guess
what
right next night and great a whole
week's destroy our become the same
problem Kratos Kratos you're saying the
same thing I'm saying why have internet
on that system you don't have games to
utilize it you have a Playstation and
you're paying for Internet to play
multiplayer right they told you this
time now that they think they told you
go any uh up now mother was free it's
cool when it's me now any up anytime and
if you wanna play the old stuff we got
PlayStation now tune in pay the same
money that you keep that same energy
paid us a money for the whole game
they'll Microsoft give you for free see
Microsoft been telling you that you
gotta pay for the old stuff like you
just you brought up the old stuff is
free we made it look better take your
Xbox 360 games makes it make it look
better you know I'll give you that it
makes it look better but guess what at
the end of the day it still it's my 360
game it doesn't turn halo 3 into halo 6
and that's part of the problem is the
sparrow colossus 5 you know what they
pick and choose the best games that the
people are asking for
they remaster them they don't you hey
you guys go to gamestop and by your old
disc again or will
you're making my point for me
you're making my point for me why every
console I gotta buy the same game over
and you put extra hair on the back of
the donkey you know why do I gotta do
this why do I gotta give them another
$60 Michaels a yo-yo if you happen to
have this game you love so much to give
you this free Kratos the games are not
free to me but when I look I see
Kratos Kratos right now you're taking
the gold poles and you're throwing that
gold post down a block like every time I
come and I scored touchdown you telling
me is not a touchdown tell me that your
multi play experience is warranted I
don't see where if all your games are
one play a single player closet
experiences right all of them now one of
them launched with a multiplayer
component the inner except for Uncharted
and that is piss-poor when it was a
multiplayer 20 I'm going to give you
listen I'm going to give you that
multiplayer I'm going to give you that
ok when's the last time you played it
listen I've got new games right above
face of new games and new experiences
you you don't have a reason to look
backwards we move this is why ok this is
right Sony at the you know you
now here's the thing that i agree with
you i love backwards compatibility or
people enjoy their that is a great
accent i think that's a huge Microsoft
Xbox asset but here's the problem right
I wouldn't mind it so much if there was
new games consistently going also with
the option I feel like it's a pacifier
to pacify people into those games don't
tease me with something else because
you're lacking all when you get split
down the middle listen we got multi play
over here you got single play over there
is is divisive right you know 100% I
love you right so I don't want anybody
to think that I'm going we tweet each
other we support each other this is real
um spider-man is coming up next
yes right I would love to play a
multiplayer spider-man game with venom
in it it's not gonna happen but if it
came out for Microsoft would but it's
not it's coming out for Sony I'll tell
you why this is where I think an Xbox
fan base or two totally different people
right and I think it's because the
companies have shaped them to be that
way like Xbox is known for being the
shooter box in the racer box I mean can
we all agree with that Sony is a known
for being the single player or story
driven game box that's just kind of
woody right so therefore if you have a
straight huh [ __ ] in your online
multiplayer be for free I don't think so
because there are there's a lot that
comes with the freeness you see them
saying there's a lot as a matter of fact
the frame
[Laughter]
as far as how good the Xbox Live is
reports came out like at the end of the
year showing that PSC was beat up online
for having the best multiplex well guess
what guess where Sony's multiplayer is
it the multiplex so don't not Sony for
that when your home console is based on
multi plans
mmm it is it is I want you to I want you
to get this part right here if we only
played our exclusive games on our
systems right yeah let's just say we
only played the exclusive games for the
system yes
would it be necessary for you to have
that internet connection that you pay
for PlayStation if you only played games
that came out this year for me you got
Xbox but I'm talking about your
PlayStation side your PlayStation side
don't like that you right you right you
right and guess what we don't got a war
we don't got Oh would you rather have
see if the user got a war no engine
rattles great
Kratos Vado's more time and steer deeds
and I'd fall asleep when I was playing
maybe around 20 to 30 hours in cm
thieves and a lot of it extreme you know
I got a bunch of people that you know
I'm on Twitter so I have I think it had
to be because it's a single-player games
do you have to go back to an inferior
version
and I like to play in the comfort of the
couch and stuff like that like I like it
I think the first Attila T Microsoft
gives you when it comes to playing games
is just like from the PC I don't want
disrespect or none of my PC games
because you're right
PC is the best place to play if you're
looking for the best performance but as
far as me I'm a console gamer I like the
ease of just the Box plugging it in go
on my controller in the ecosystem
already there old-school games this is
why guys this is why I am against going
all digital and streaming and stuff like
that I want to be able to stand outside
in a line you know with different people
waiting for a console launch that's just
that's that old-school nature are you
yeah no I'm pretty good at it you want
to jump in I completely agree and I feel
like that's one of the key reasons
Microsoft's where they are right now is
because they abandon that at the
beginning of this generation how many of
those are single-player games right and
which now simply leap into the next time
okay look look at games like would you
besides Poggi what is the last console
cellar you would consider it's been on
the Microsoft platform there you go they
you know when was the last time you had
a game of caliber I'm talking about
garden workout or anything just a
console cellar in general we can say pub
Gino pub gee I said besides bungee oh
you said beside will go back to you know
maybe gears I mean I dead that's that's
debatable Oh genre I think the last key
one they had was titanfall
that was halo 5 what are all these games
have in common multiplayer
well let's build this topic which was
perfect time actually with the Darryl
gallon enjoying obviously just announced
cradles obviously that he's gonna join
at Microsoft Studios executive leading
team leadership team you had the
tremendous experience from you know
Square Enix Activision THQ he's head of
the Tomb Raider reboot so you know
Courtney shot up my man Lauren got great
video please check it out you know
Cornwall ran and a lot of us we think
that this is this guy is gonna be
responsible for heading a Microsoft
studio and actually my board
integrations for it that's right so his
resume tremendous this guy's a veteran
so what do the Lord sting and I'm
actually start credit he's in here as
far as like this recommitment by
Microsoft to try and add these pieces
and we know this thing kind of takes
time right we know that we don't expect
this God announces necessarily I'll be
shocked
you know he's they said they want to but
what do you think about marks of at
least trying to make that moves and get
better in the home for your marks for
first party state what do you feel about
stuff like this look I think it's great
we all know that they're in a rebuilding
process right this generation is to Xbox
it's kind of been like the Wii U you
know what do you disagree women I kind
of hear me out real quick it has been
like the Wii U as what we you was to
Nintendo right it didn't do what they
thought it was gonna do so they had to
go back you know a lot of stuff happened
we don't have to rehash we know what
happened from 2013 all the way to now so
they got to get some fresh blood in
there they got to get some some things
moving some people who know with the
fans want in any of this and so right
now they're working on the future
they're working on next generation this
generation they're just gonna kind of
limp along with that's why they offer
you services and stuff along with 40 so
we let me know please
now y'all happy to be jogging I give you
jogging you doing you doing your Barry
Bonds sprint I'm gonna give you that
that Olympic you can stop that listen we
do guys like we supposed system that's a
run that's done right a as robust as
ours that's out the window okay coming
for you
well listen here keep looking over your
shoulder keep being afraid because
you're pigeonhole yourself experience il
play experiences okay I think it's great
anytime we get anybody that's gonna
change the philosophy on how things go
and if he has a background and video
games to bring us up as the studios we
need that because we can't try this
pigeon shoehorn multi playing everything
that's what happened to UM scalebound
right he was trying to pigeon hole
multi-play scalebound this nobody would
have probably been that great single
player experience but they kept trying
to shoehorn Oh puddin friends together
sometimes it don't work so my multi
player again is great right
I will admit right even Sony said is a
TSX
they do what they do best in that single
story live games the best thing they can
do is make some you know you have to be
multiplayer like it could be caught
stuff like stage of decay they need a
single well and you know obviously
students are there single-player games
because you know he does not single
players games fantastic but they still
have multiplayer games yeah you know
focus on that get your you know games
like titanfall unique experiences that
you can only experience on that platform
of that console choice you know I feel
like there is a couple games I have
potential they need to do whatever they
can they need to get that rise IP they
must I shout out the mic a borrow for
hinting did you saw that cryptic team
when he was in the studios and he had
that statue of rise oh man I've said
from the start I've said that I wouldn't
be surprised if Microsoft bought that IP
in secret and then told anyone because
let's be injured was sold what happened
to the IP you mean to tell me you know
broke cryo tech kept the IP for no
reason like they have it but it will be
interesting to see if a deal was reached
you know something like that sunset
overdrive thanks is ready to be made the
developers saying hey Mac we should need
a publisher and Microsoft on there and
that's kind of part of look people are
screaming they cancelled the games
without having anything to replace them
with and that's how they they got some
good ideas that I think you work with
people are asking for rise to some said
overdrive to and a couple of others I
just got to prove it together
to be honest with you I played sunset
overdrive from beginning to end it was a
cool game but I mean it's not for you
though I like it is a beloved let's be
real it's not for a lot of people it
didn't even sell that well at all
I hate what you saying but you think
they should abandon it completely and
not make a sequel not not
I'm never against uncharted one like
that I feel like they had more to work
with in sunset over job one coming on
charge what was so wrong
Thank You Superfriends the premise isn't
for everybody like you have that net
over the top star a comedic thing like
no the hope the premise is not fair it
was a cool game and usually used a lot
of what they learned on sunset overdrive
to make spider-man mm-hm
but it's just not something that you
know it's not it's not it's not
something that's gonna grab a lot of not
an event game and I get how funny
how funny it is that the the creator of
sunset overdrive ended up doing spider
Pass what I'm like or anything like that
but I mean that doesn't surprise me
you could be acting like they all I'm
saying is at the end of the day it's not
for me I'm not even a sunset overdrive
fan like that but I do understand the
diversity the pro4 portfolio and own in
this I agree that you know there's a lot
of I agree that every game deserves a
sequel at least but that is one
particular game and quantum break
because corner break was trash I can
understand you know let's be real here
like not only you know there might be a
lot of people that hyped that game but
let's be honest here like what Ana
numbers agree with you right the numbers
based on the sale it's not even that
like besides the couple people like Xbox
ain't listening to 40 people on Twitter
not a pill to the mass the difference
though you're right all I'm saying is
Kratos makes a good point
look at uncharted one that did not set
the world on fire you know I'm saying
but they stuck with there's got to be a
time where
at some point whether it be a Rika maybe
not sunset overdrive right maybe it's
like a recoil franchise that they had
under their roof they need to revisit
it's not a good look that these
franchises are sitting there dormant and
the devs you got in Sonic like cradles
are saying say hey we would love to make
a sequel for sunset overdrive Microsoft
said so but that's a bad look and you
know after that like you know unless the
way that they've worded that that
cryptic tweet I'm really starting to
think they might own that IP but
Microsoft owns owns that IP ironic that
you know they say well when Microsoft
good we good for sunset overdrive too
it's like then why don't you go to
someone else it's like it's like we go
to Microsoft it's a movie studio you
have to a lot the blockbusters per year
on how they're gonna come out you can't
you know jumble them all up together you
know is the reason why there's a certain
amount of Marvel movies that come out of
here and they give you a four year plan
we have no roadmap when it comes to
Microsoft yeah
that's the big problem and it seems like
they have nothing we know they have
stuff but it seems like they have
nothing have to do it they have to give
you something of a row matter have to
give you some breadcrumbs to say this is
what we're working towards they can't
write can't come out of III having no I
had no idea what's going on it that's
why and that's why this again notice may
be overstated but I think this is a good
sign right when you seeing these guys
saying that their Highness guy with this
tremendous experience to have basically
won his own don't be fooled like they
announced that he came on to onto their
team recently but that dudes been there
for a couple months at least
and those two announced him because they
wanted to get high because I do believe
something like that is coming yes to do
if I can the fact that my booty was like
yo he's gonna share more about
Gallagher's role III they're setting
something up
let's be clear this is marketing
one-on-one this is how you set things up
then when you do these cryptic tweaks
and you showing yourself at Rhys you
know you did doing little things to set
up the potential of them reinvesting in
first-party that's all I'm saying I
would say one thing I wasn't the way
that I don't know who tweeted it but I
think it was Phil Spencer he tweeted
that you know people - actually they
they dissected the tweet and they made
fun of it but it was like what their
overall initiative is for this III it
was like you know a uh show stuff that's
in work and show stuff for the future
the way that they worded that I can't
remember exactly I think it will know
what you're talking about
yeah your and beyond I think that's
exactly how they thought I was worded
that he said that he thinks our Galica
is gonna be leading fable that would be
amazing
I don't when it comes to that particular
phrase you don't use that kind of phrase
if it's just next year right absolutely
I think then they realized that I mean
let's be real here they realize we have
stuff we just have to show it and I
think they're gonna break that we're
only showing this year next thing I
dream I think they're gonna break down
that protocol solve les last point for
the thing with with Xbox and I like the
fact that they do need the variety still
need the variety they should have sunset
overdrive - they should have rise to the
thing is when you compare them to what
someone is doing yes the cultures are
very different what a PlayStation game
expects and what Xbox game respects the
thing about it is at the end of the day
you have not had a marquee release in
the vein of a God of War not necessarily
that type of game I'm just talking about
impactful vent
it's neat you're open you're right these
releases are events mm-hmm I haven't
seen an event release for Xbox let's be
real an event release what halo 3 you
rent you see if these wasn't sure of it
what franchise has the cachet I kind of
feel like you know it didn't have
because you can't really put them on the
same levels at all because you know
titanfall is a multiplayer game and this
is a single-player game you're gonna
have a lot more people in ER but I feel
like you know God of War is getting more
of an impact but a lot of people when it
first came out
overdrive god what it is now there
wasn't nobody standing around the block
wait you forgot hold up I was one of
them God of War one it was a block down
there was a line down the block on 86th
Street Game Stop you guys have all this
revisionist history stuff going no no no
no let's be real means it's not about
multiplayer versus single-player is the
status of you need your franchises that
have these marquee releases Halo lost
that it's not it used to be anymore
years 1 & 2 with that let me actually
okay we know halo gears and Forza right
there long in the tooth would if halo
and would've Gears decided to pull a a
God of War and reboot right that's why
a comma with a now it may be a culture
shock - it's funny you said let me cut
you one second cream because you yet
you're jumping on something you're
kneeling something that being Lord
anchorman was talking about I thought
five was gonna do that because they were
setting it up with the lock right
laughter okay they might be doing
something drastic
that's good might piss people off but
they change in the direction anything
like completely formidable and lied in a
way as to what the premise of what that
that would away was presented in the
trailer so I feel you I think what it is
is like you said sometimes when you have
something that's safe you've got to
shake it up sometimes the player can be
the frame oh right that way you have the
darts they have what they need it but
you can also have that single player
game that you do that story-driven the
shoulder you can do all the duties doing
and give it to you separately for $30
come let me say this
i'ma say this to you you solo experience
i'ma say this to you captain solo um I'm
still waiting for you so I can finish
the game I started tell me I'm playing a
pub gee when I got dudes that wanna play
pub G and I wanna play this game that I
started with you and you're still over
there doing a little sideshow I want to
say that you know I do completely agree
I do feel like there when it comes to I
do know five was a good game it's story
was just messed up the multiplayer was
still played to this day it's still
nothing
and that's that's my primary example
it's like look like I I'm sorry like
gears need to go like always safe okay
to safe they should have killed Phoenix
I feel like coalition needs to make
something new that's gory that's two
player co-op in that just ripped [ __ ]
apart he uh I feel like there wasn't
black studio that was supposed to be
doing one here the gears and it wasn't
supposed to be coalition and it was
really supposed to be dark and it was
supposed to be a real crazy reboot the
blackness they were black and then they
they they said no you're gonna make
years from now on I really think they
should've went in that direction that
black Tufts had and maybe we will get
that again you know maybe we will get it
under different Monica maybe they feel
that you know they sense they only have
five games that there's not a willing to
camp
within five I'm sorry if I'm gonna fill
these dudes with the five games saying
movie those stay true to these because
if we lose one of these five we only got
the same stuff you're gonna lose it
anyway tell me this wouldn't sound cool
like if you're not good like okay at the
end of that I think that they don't want
to make anything that's not Halo and
Gears because unlike Sony important it's
easier to talk to the corporate about a
loss Saudis like okay we've been in this
industry for a long time it's our
biggest moneymakers here is fine go do
something else but I go to the
microphone financially better than Sony
as a company first have taken a little
bit more wrists in so anyway we listen
Sony has to knock it out to be the one
like that's a cool concept and
technically they're doing better but up
until now until recently they didn't
even have a seat at the table
gamings all up no you're right you're
right and now Phil's at the table now
Sachi got Phil at the table these are
now Phil's vision a little looking
smiling like I said on Lucas podcast
yesterday you know natural Vista but he
said don't be sorry be better I am done
regardless how you feel about Phil
Spencer and I've said multiple times you
know I'm not sure how he's doing he's
not the guy
you have to look at it from perspective
of every game that has come out in the
past two years
ain't been Phil Spencer [ __ ] I honestly
when he came in he said he had he had a
road map he was gonna work on and I said
this exact thing and Lucas thing and I
stand by he said he was gonna work on
Hardware sir game services exclusive
games I don't necessarily like a lot of
people took that concept and they're
like well is he going to do them in
order I don't think he was go he put
that perspective in order he put it put
it in the specter of what is gonna take
the longest and one can I do this and
one can I do that and hear it and they
realize they can do hardware first games
as a service because games take longer
than both of those ships so they can't
walk took five years to crate what
horizon took four years right but all I
want to say this Kratos is that you're
absolutely right they should be able to
walk on through John it's game time and
do the same thing that's when you're
doing but in attics defense which is
this is the first time I'm actually at
there so that's a sign of where they
were prioritizing things
like it wasn't really a prior like
gaming kind of came it was the
successful other little thing that they
were doing that's now blowing up and
let's be honest Windows Phones and I'm
other things have kind of gone by the
wayside you know I'm saying
shout out to tired tired named Meyerson
don't like that but we glad Phil is at
the table we glad he's got his position
so I just want to see I agree we can't
go into this mentality which is like
just wrong metallic that's what I
playing god
right now at the end of the day I've
said it you know I've got jumped on a
Planet X box for doing the same thing
right you can't spin well let's take
this calendar for instance yes what was
yesterday the 21st that's a Saturday
right you can't make a video on the 21st
saying X Box got no games and then make
a video what was a week from the 23rd Oh
first the 28th st. Xbox out no games
it's a week fam you can't make a game in
a week you just keep making the mode the
same repetitive video over and over to
be done a week like I said but in Kratos
is defense well there's you know it's
it's tough out here in these xbox
streets if you don't have a games like
you don't have feeling way that why is
it my platform kind of providing those
type of experience that they had this is
something we've said multiple times
absolutely Sony for the most part
they've been a stable gaming industry
the entire time you know last year they
did the thought last gen they did a
thumb bull
you know when people didn't know that
was gonna work but you six get a second
job regardless how it goes and
regardless what kind of excuses it's not
our fault but not only did they have the
entire 2013 I did not mean to say that I
father had that then we go to they had
the change of leadership not only on an
Xbox level like Phil Spencer he went to
the leadership they changed leadership
2010 they promoted him they had the CEO
leadership change as well did an entire
restructure the entire I mean the the
software on a level if you go from the
original 2013 Xbox software to now
Nelson he said why can't you just flip a
switch and fix it Major Nelson said we
couldn't do it in people they laughed
autumn when they did it they couldn't do
they had to strip the entire software
and start from fresh why do you think
that pop-ups from
sparks were what how long ago a long
before they still had to undo everything
that was done during the match just
watch this any time you sit then you
felt that rolling off the tongue and I
want you to notice right when it's light
that up all your dues start disappearing
on that sunny side way to power the
power is done all right games as a
service game pass is flourishing in a
nice situation backwardly compatible all
that stuff throw that in there that's a
little extra he told you two games is
coming the games is coming we understand
what you saying like it could to compare
them right now Sony to way I look at it
right now and I had this conversation
with we also gotta just give credit
where credit is on the first party won't
waste like Jordan in a 90's right now
later you could have the Pistons the
Showtime Lake this is Jordan in the
night they just on a phenomenal run
these just got a real rededicate to what
they're saying they're gonna do with
these first party students these
announcements of what they saying and
let's just see what the roadmap is for
the future that's all we gotta go back
in the draft call of duty single player
has been move everybody pretty much
knows what's going on the last thing is
on what you called it apparently they're
supposed to be a battle royal mode in
place I love
I would get some in this as well um what
do we think about it do we think this
day sets a dangerous precedent president
moving forward law solve no singleplayer
quality Becca for thing I play for the
single I like the stories I mean I think
the engines a little long in the tooth
they've run it with up the engine and
make it different but um I just think it
why call it black ops for them like what
what are you are you what do you feel
about perceived value should as far as
the $60 $60 game yeah definitely have a
problem with that they haven't said like
they said there's no single player
campaign but I know people have been
pining for um that co-op multiplayer
about what it's called now no not the
zombies people kind of tired of zombies
um it was in modern warfare 2 was a spec
op something like that it was called
something like that way it wasn't it was
I think it was story centric um
multiplayer like co-op stuff if they do
something like that and add some kind of
story to it that would be cool just to
switch up the formula a little bit
that'd be cool
leaders knows multiple sources polygon
you're a game of Kotaku Charlie campaign
but it just doesn't make any sense to me
to call a black ops for after that cuz
you're not this is gonna ship mostly
with a multi player without a campaign
and possibly even software at the end of
the day they got the stats they know who
beats these things they know you're
gonna beat these things
yeah as much as people hate it there's
gonna be 10 people to that one person
like that's good I don't care alright
attic what about perceived value do you
think not buying this game any no I know
you're not buying it but we're saying
what about should they still be able to
charge $60 is that okay to you do you
think it should not but you know they're
going to the I don't know how many maps
at the beginning they'd be okay with $60
they give you like
we'd of like 30 Maps is it a way to be
30 minutes exactly what they they
normally give you and they're going have
that hand popped out but like where's my
money
opposite of all these guys that play
multiplayer I could have call of duty
and I never touched both playing at one
time no Laurie Mason zombies thing I
thought zombies was crap well I think
honestly I thought they multiplayers
like tacked on BS nori was where was
that for me because that's where he was
able to dive into the graphics part of
the engine and he was able to exploit
and show stuff set pieces always looked
a call of duty as the big-budget movie
and battlefield as the the b-class movie
trying to keep up to be honest with you
and the stories have always captivated
me to keep playing on never once if you
look at my profile never exhausted I
really unlike multiplayer this affects
you know these games
I won't purchase you know in the same
breath that you have a pub G type of
battle royale my and I'm gonna have over
watch shout out to be money in a chat
making a good point about $60 so
overwatch and everybody didn't have no
problem with that I did
okay thanks you follow with that I have
a huge problem when you tell me it's
multiplayer only around deathmatch and
you know well you know me is a hundred
people if I had a map with four of my
friends and I can stretch it out their
matches is like 45 bits and stuff like
that I think that really intrigues me
that's why I play pop G but when you
tell me I'm gonna be running around
spawn killing and and and respawning and
that is idiotic to me it has no place in
my DNA I don't choose to do it I know
you're gonna say you played halo and he
was doing it with your friends it was
nice and when it was the first that did
it but we're
somebody keeps doing that saying
one-trick pony it gets tiresome I'm not
about it
all right look Kratos what do you feel
all right well I also think that as a
person who spent $60 on sea of themes
that don't have a story for this game it
didn't have a single player I mean it
didn't have a single player component
and even have a he was excited for the
game because I have something it's like
I feel like I'm gonna get too
overwhelmed in that game and ain't know
it I'll be happy with that so you got no
bar and I got nobody to play with
there was that one guy that said he got
mad when everybody was talking about it
was no Kraken body he said I want away
[Applause]
you don't have a problem with you have
no issue with it or you have problem
overall I'll call it B no singleplayer
you don't have so I mean come on brother
damn give me the shoe horn some shitty
story in there wasting waste wasting
resources wasting time I don't have a
problem with $60 right I don't have
problem with that because I expect him
to throw a bunch of maps in there right
I'm gonna jump in my opinion a little
different everybody's got their own
thing with it I don't have a problem
with them removing it you know I mean
listen I don't I know for the people who
like singleplayer that sucks but I do
agree that the metric probably do show
and the achievement tracking list to
show that people weren't playing it and
you know let's be honest the resources
there to create that that takes money
however I disagree with the fact that if
they're gonna do this but basically
looking at perceived value if everything
you gave me prior to this always this
full package you gave me meat and
potatoes you gave me a dessert you gave
me all this other stuff right now this
new version now you're talking about you
just giving me the meat I don't get no
cheesecake I don't get no side dishes
that yeah oh my core duties had a fool
you know Boston Walker situation so why
you just giving me the turkey and
slapping it on the middle and expecting
me to pay 64 that's just well but I
would like because this is what you're
valuable you should like to watch you
like to know it's there if I wonder what
they have a little single-player peach
cobbler on the side I should be able to
had it we're going I got a quest
King because again if if they just give
you the same old Call of Duty
multiplayer and happy don't change you
significantly make it better like Kratos
says that a problem with that
so my bet is they're really banking on
this this battle royale stuff to really
take now for King who plays who plays a
lot of pub gee do you think cuz I for
what I perceived with pub G's that
people prefer to play that in third
person
mmm-hmm oh say that first person how
does that translate to Call of Duty
being a battle royale game cuz to me a
lot of they might have the third person
option in it
you think so you think they change up
what would traditionally be Call of Duty
to make it fit into what you know Battle
Royale
what's that bag we seen with cliffie be
doing right now yeah everybody Knight
bag let's just do you have the option in
pub G to play for a third person you can
lot right yes so I'm surprised that most
people don't like to do that they have
separate service for that like most
people would like to play into a person
you know you can mix it to like why are
you playing the game you can just stay
in a first person if you choose so I
believe that option will be available to
you what they gonna do is they're gonna
dissect it successful right and you know
this is EA men so they're gonna actually
make sure that after Dyson is successful
see what I mean Activision sorry I'm
thinking about battlefield because they
have a pop up G joint coming to num and
they're gonna you know they do all
analytics to see what they know what and
if it's comparable both ways they're
gonna say you know what let's just put
both of them options in there or if not
that the community will cry for it
that's one make no mistake about that
towards I agree with you this is a test
run to see how the community reacts and
if the community made me prove me wrong
they just say hey we come by just at
multiplayer and you know it is what it
is yo we got to wrap it up we had three
I mom
Impa everybody gotta go I know
everybody's doing a rap ups alright well
new poll when neutral gaming media
outlets run imagery or articles that may
be perceived to poke fun of one platform
over another do you consider this to be
media bias against that platform the
answers are a no performance dictates
coverage no media bias exists B yes it
is definitely a conspiracy against
certain platforms see maybe some
journalists do have biases well D I
don't care Yama get what you got cooking
up for you so I'm gonna be there and
everybody can find no further where I do
my work hey dub 16 GPU guys laughing
with the gifts and the means you know
what I mean absolute pleasure to have
more Kratos in the round coming down
[Laughter]
people find you any more difficult ging
conquers you savage beating god of war
so fast I'm so mad at you actually right
now I'm working on the in-game content
like they actually have like really
strong bosses and stuff you can fight
sure
Rados can a call a comment on that but
you follow me on twitter of something
IOP I think it's more I can't remember
boy get your name right you can find me
on pretty much any kind of gaming outlet
PlayStation Xbox it's all room to kill
yes I do know that I should make gaming
addict no I don't need to comment about
it so I definitely appreciate everyone
coming by we'll see you next week
what's going on Twitter I'm gonna be a
Instagram Facebook all that live stream
chrome is armed I wanted to just be like
this great thing I want I want y'all to
understand this right um a lot of you
guys have purchased the shirts I want
y'all to tweet that out it's gonna be a
thing with that to be taking the are
they do tweets with that and you're
gonna be getting discounts because
of that because you have purchased your
promoted and you should be rewarded and
then that's gonna happen for you um
these new shirts is coming in crazy
colors and I have the the female woman
gamer in mind I want you all to step out
and be proud of your gaming you notice
that the iron Lords logo has PlayStation
Xbox and switch is not just you know
Xbox logo it's for everyone so you know
please get the shirts please get at us
and they don't represent the movement
the movement is unity resented at one
point so as you see Kratos is here we
joke around we play it out but we all
play together mm-hmm
facts that's what's up man crosses more
kognito here another one in the books
again shout out the lockers were coming
through man and what I love about
credits is like he wraps his platform
but we can still we got our platformer
we can still come and have fun you don't
say and just debate and is all love and
that's what we need in the community man
it's what's up and shout everybody who
uh you know took the time out for the
whole Xbox adding thing that was real
good to see like I said the community
come together we lost our gaming
brethren links in the description for
the gold fund me for his family you know
I'm saying wife the kids and all that
make sure everybody's okay on give
everybody the chat chat was absolutely
live or shout out to eat boxes for us
2012 is up destiny little little
comeback yeah yeah might want to listen
interested definite that out when I
little pocket shout to all people who
given love for the packs he's coverage
we got a lot of stuff cooking up now
everybody enjoy a sunny we know this was
a long one boy with cradles in the
building it was too fun to start
anything else to say we out of here
everybody good boy boy